hey guys it's justine and today i'm with
my friend farooq how
are you i'm well how are you so we both
did unboxing videos of our flamethrowers
on our channel i'll put links in the
description to both of those but today
we are doing something
um a little different it's a little
picnic i wanted to go on a picnic so bad
yeah and now we are we've been so busy
editing videos deserve it we did
we definitely do we decided to go
outside and i've got some food here so
what's going to happen is we're going to
each choose some items so each take a
turn pick our favorite item and then
we're going to cook those said items on
our channels
that's perfect this is going to be great
have you guys seen the flamethrower with
those have you guys seen these yet
in case you guys haven't seen them oh
baby should we give them a little taste
test
mine is not caving
somebody call 911. all right let's get
cooking
do you want to go first and pick your
first item may i yes
all right i'd like to pick salmon
i love grilled cheese so i'm gonna take
the grilled cheese i like to make some
baked potatoes so i'm gonna take this
burger
[Music]
so now we have our items now it's time
to take them on fire
i really have no idea how this is gonna
happen we have so much
propane we're gonna we're gonna be able
to save the world so in the course of
this video the sun is probably gonna go
down but it is what it is
the flames will only look brighter so i
think the first thing that i need to do
is i need to burn the tags off of
these items this tank is probably going
to be empty very shortly
that's melting that's
definitely melting what's the first item
do you think we should cook
[Music]
should probably keep my eye on this
burning tag
hot dogs everybody loves hot dogs
everybody does love hot dogs
what's the secret for a delicious hot
dog uh you know i'm not sure we're gonna
find out but i think i've got an idea
what if we jam the hotdogs
on onto here this was the best part oh
my gosh
yeah there's cheese inside of these hot
dogs there is cheddar cheese
inside of here i've never tried to
juggle hot dogs before let's see if it's
a thing oh wow i can juggle hot dogs
this is incredible the more you know
let's do it
oh yeah oh that cheat oh these are these
are cooking up real quick real nice
the cheese is starting to just
like flow out of it
like a volcano do you like yours well
done
yes please cool
oh no there's a wiener down
okay well i guess we can put it on yeah
we have to
yeah here's one for you thank you i
guess we just kind of
they're already pre-cut
oh it's yeah don't eat it do not okay i
was like do not do that because i will
throw up
on right now it smells cooked it's
delicious i feel like we should be going
to like a baseball game or something now
hot dogs you can flame throw them
you can throw flames on them i'm not
sure so i pretend
ate it and i'm giving you a pretend ten
out of ten because how delicious that
was
thank you let's try to make an egg
[Music]
right now we're gonna make eggs
i gotta preheat the pan to get it nice
and
ready for cooking
do you wanna get an egg ready yeah all
right get us an egg
do you wanna crack the egg in there
careful don't get burned because that's
probably very hot
whoa okay look out look out
come on don't you just hate it when your
flame thrower gives up right in the
middle of cooking
i'm just gonna do this until this tank
runs out this looks like
the surface of a planet that's something
that's definitely cooked
you know when your friend's coming over
that you don't want
them for too long in the house
hey guys brunch is here you know we
should do let's throw that burger on
there too since we're down here
this yeah oh
right on top of the egg look it's
cooking it's already cooking
listen to that
[Music]
how do you like your burger meeting well
me too
it's amazing that egg
is still cooking i think the egg is
starting to catch on fire so i'm
basically
running this tank out and you can also
see that the tank is starting to freeze
up
yeah this tank is definitely frozen
smells awesome by the way and by that i
mean
terrible it smells so bad
this is actually almost well done cook
that burger
whoa
here let me flip it
[Music]
here's our burger look at this ew like
it's
this pan is so hot ick all right let's
cook something else
i think it's time to pop corn i feel
like we're supposed to put oil or
something in the pan but i think there's
enough oil in there from that burger
that this will do whatever it needs to
do
i'll tell you what those things are not
safe see it's got to be facing up
the problem is it popping
not here do you think we should both do
it
how is this not popping yet popping
popping there it goes there it is
we're making popcorn like we're gonna
use a whole tank
trying to pop popcorn but it's happening
it's definitely i mean there's popcorn
all over the place and it's getting
caught with water
oh my gosh that is amazing there is
popcorn and it smells so good
i was hitting me in the head can you
believe this right now what's happening
this is not how i thought my thursday
saturday friday
today okay i think we can officially say
the popcorn work
it did work
off
it's not turning off oh god
guys i can't turn my mind won't turn off
[Music]
i may have burned my fake grass but
that's okay
it's all for the sake of art there's
popcorn everywhere
i guess we'll just throw these pop-tarts
in there yeah why not oh my god i love
pop-tarts
no i'm good thank you
oh my god this is a great pop tart these
are s'mores pop-tarts by the way i'm
trying to put the fire out
definitely ruin my grass
have you ever put a fire out with eggs
we don't need no water let the popcorn
burn burn my grass the best part about
all of this is we have flamethrowers and
we have a fake fire hydrant
it's not real my dog pees on this which
is totally fine because the grass is
fake too
i'm gonna have them come and be like hey
can you replace a very small piece of my
grass
oh yeah um i was making popcorn in my
backyard and it caught
on fire all right time to open up my
young chicken with my machete
like for being this massive it's very
ineffective
oh gosh now there's chicken juice
everywhere
one slice of cheese or two slices of
cheese
so two and the secret to a great grilled
cheese sandwich
is buttered oh yeah yeah this is my
family secret actually
do you think your family's ever used a
flamethrower to make a grilled cheese
no we didn't have flamethrowers back
then how are we even gonna do this
should we just like take turns burning
it yes we should take turns
this may be empty after our popcorn
excursion oh yep that's promising
[Music]
you guys can't see it but he is crispy
he's got a crispy bottom
i'm going to get to the front so yeah
you might want to come over here
[Music]
who would have thought fake grass and
flames don't mix
how is that bread not caught on fire yet
is surprising
nicely toasted are you joking is it no
no no i wasn't joking
i mean i see that this part got burned
yeah a little bit crisp
[Music]
yes that's what we're talking about
i mean i think that's good enough yeah
it's not like we're gonna eat it
[Music]
you ready to see perfection see i told
you
you're right it actually looks really
good yeah the corner is
burnt but it's a little crisp yeah but
look at that and he
probably needs to coach a little bit
more this little leg didn't get very tan
this one's nice and crispy this is
something that happened today
a lot of things have happened burned my
grass but
there is still more fun to be had over
on your channel
yes now we will use different food
and see how they behave against against
our flamethrowers well guys thank you so
much for watching hope you enjoyed this
video make sure you check out his
channel
there is more cooking fun to be had over
there this was amazing we had so much
fun
thank you so much for joining me thank
you so much for having me yes
it's probably once in a lifetime
experience right well
i mean we've got two flamethrowers now
so this can happen anyway
the first one that's true well guys
we'll see you later
thanks for watching bye happy burning
[Music]
do
you